[Music]  bachelor in paradise stars Carly Waddell  and Evan paths are having a baby girl it  was a great surprise okay the newlyweds  confirm the news to ET on Saturday evan  telling ET they both wept when they  heard the news from their doctor quote  we were shocked and elated I didn't  think I could produce a girl it feels  like a miracle baby evan has three sons  from a previous relationship the two  announced they were expecting their  first child together  earlier this month and he typed names  yet yes well no he's like what can I say  I've been jr. no it's he's like telling  everyone it's gonna be named Evan  regardless and I'm like so no I would be  a really cute girl's name yeah I think  that's so confusing cuz if I'm like mad  and I'm like Evan then you both run in  early but you know like that's so  confusing that is confusing I think now  you think alright he was like I have  these great idea  [Music]  you